attempts over half of my lifetime, 75 now, have failed to correct chronic fatigue.
I know it's fighting. See, of course, it didn't have done nothing. No indications of any infectious
disease that might only clue I have is that my deep fatigue is very seasonal. It's at its worst right now
mid-June. Thought I was on to something thinking that spring was allergy season and nitric oxide
production might be impeding in the days of the nasal passages, daily dose of fermented
beat powder, and other nitric oxide producers seem to help at first, but that it didn't.
More sun and more exercise, just wherever you go. Yeah, so I wish I had a dime for every time people
ask questions like this because I feel so sad for them because this is kind of the state
of what's going on. People are struggling because they're not getting answers. And again,
I think you're not going to get answers if you're not fighting somebody that's going to continue
to ask the right questions. And I do feel bad because a lot of people will contact us and say,
I can't afford to run these labs. I've spent all my money and they spent their money on doing
getting promises like, oh, we're going to just do IV vitamin C in personal ethics. Those are
expensive things to do on a regular basis, but you got to dig to find the cost. So when you go,
okay, what can be some possible issues with product overwhelming fatigue?
Well, certainly post COVID, chronic viruses, including COVID can be linked to that.
You have tested against no indications of infectious diseases. I'd like to see what labs
this person read. Product fatigue. So remember we talked about microglial priming and neurological
functions. That's something you always want to go back to because it's fairly easy to know if
something, if something has a cause in the periphery or if something has a cause in, let's call
your upper motor neurons, or let's say your brain is spinal cord. So if your brain is at cause,
the symptoms are going to be a little bit more vague. So put it this way. If I smash my toe and
my toe is throbbing, I know the cause was I smashed my toe and my toe has to heal. Now,
the pain that I feel in my toe is actually firing up my sensory neurons into my brain or the
opposite side of my pride along my brain. That's where I actually feel the pain. But I know the
cause because I know I smashed my toe. But let's say I have a little bit more vague symptoms.
My toe hurts at different times, but sometimes it's not always my right toe. Sometimes it's my right D,
and sometimes it things move around like we talked about before. It's just a little bit more vague.
Then you start thinking that it's more of an upper motor neuron. Is the inflammation actually in my brain?
When you got more obvious upper motor neuron issues like the chronic fatigue,
what could my chronic fatigue be? Well, years ago people would just go, it's probably your
needles. You had a needle insufficiency. Well, maybe that's it, but you could easily test for that.
Doing a 24-hour cortisol test and seeing your cortisol changes is a good test,
testing DHEA as well as a good test to test for that. I've had people with serious
chronic fatigue, serious emotional issues, serious imbalances with mood issues, anxiety issues,
but they have perfect cortisol balance. It's not their Doritos. They don't have a Doritos burnout.
It's not their partuitary. Could it be something else that's were digging to that in most people that
are in that category have serious gut inflammation? And remember, if you have a Cyrex array 10 or a
food sensitivity panel with a lot of things in the red and yellow, that means you have serious gut
inflammation in rule number one. If you have gut inflammation, you have brain inflammation.
Then if you have brain inflammation, you could have the biggest different types of symptoms that move
around peripheral symptoms that move around and or symptoms that are
connected to brain inflammation like fatigue or brain fog or loss of, can't remember things or
obvious brain inflammation issues. So, go back again to go to our website, look up
viral inflammation and watch that video about glycophilia. I would, if you have the ability financially
to do some tests, I would get anybody testing again, array 5 and array 7x. That would be my go-to
labs for a person with that thing's they have chronic life like that other question before.
A lot of people, again, like that they they attributed to chronic life. This person's question,
they're not, they're saying they they've investigated chronic life. They don't think they have it.
Which truth is is that if you've had this chronic fatigue for over half your life, you may have had
a chronic life incidence that there's no presence of even the IgG antibodies anymore because it's been
so long. So, it doesn't make a difference what that initial cause was. Now, we know the cause of
your symptoms is either antibodies to neural tissue or microglial primate and you have to address that.
So, remember, if you have antibodies to neural tissue and or microglial primate,
you're going to have symptoms based on where in the brain that is taking place. Now, it's typically
fairly diffused through the brain, but you can have more inflammation at different parts of the brain.
So, one person can have more neurone issues and have more, you know, issues with motor function.
Person can have issues with cerebellum, have more inflammation than cerebellum. They've made
it coordination issues. Person can have issues with the phryanoloma. They're going to have more sensory
issues like pain and that moves around and sensory takes everything around. So, again, asking the right
questions, digging in and doing the different tests that would be appropriate. Again, if you need
help with any of these and, you know, your finances are extremely limited. I say spend $50 and
join the chronic disease and autoimmune course. You can find that on our website, cuttersplenic.com
or if you want more specific health, feel free to self-schedule and schedule a case review with me
and I'll gladly help you work through these things. That's really what my job is is to try to help
you work through these things. It's, you know, I don't have a magic ball that tells me what everybody's
problem is, but it's, you know, using the wisdom that you gained through, you know, increased
knowledge and increased experience, you are able to try to put people in the right direction. I'm
just trying to try to do that the best way I can. So, and you can also go to cuttersclenic.com,
again, there's plenty of blog posts on a lot of this stuff that will help you too.